do you have existing Tomcat applications
running inside of virtual machines that
you'd like to migrate to Containers but
aren't sure where to start hi I'm Mike
Coleman a developer Advocate at Google
Cloud Apache Tomcat is one of the most
commonly used Java web servers and many
Enterprises run production Java web
applications on Tomcat servers inside
virtual machines those same
organizations are looking to migrate
those applications to containers and
enjoy the benefits of containerized
cloud native environments such as Cloud
run or Google kubernetes engine
in this video we're going to take a look
at how you can use Google Cloud's
migrate to containers to help speed
those modernization efforts
it is a common practice to deploy
multiple Java applications to a single
Tomcat instance this means the day two
operations of these applications such as
deployment logging monitoring and
scaling are all tightly coupled this
approach usually comes at a high cost in
terms of deployment velocity testing and
troubleshooting
by migrating applications to containers
with migrate to Containers we will by
default generate a migration plan which
splits all these co-deployed
applications into individual containers
this allows you to benefit from not only
having a smaller footprint but also
allows you to utilize modern
capabilities such as service Discovery
elasticity Cloud logging Cloud
monitoring and automated CI CD pipelines
all of this ultimately allows you to
speed up your deployment and delivery
times while decoupling operational
dependencies
by default migrate to Containers uses
the Tomcat Community official image from
Docker Hub as the base image however
this can be replaced by your own
hardened and specifically tuned based
image and as mentioned before migrate to
Containers also recommend splitting all
the code deployed applications into
individual containers in addition to
generating kubernetes secrets for your
sense of data such as key stores and
Trust stores
once containerized these applications
can be deployed on the different
platforms supported by Google Cloud such
as anthos gke running in either standard
or autopilot mode and even our
serverless container platform Cloud run
having this breadth of choice enables
you to focus on your application's
features as opposed to managing your
infrastructure
if you're interested in learning more
about containerizing and migrating
applications to gke autopilot we have
another video that we will link down in
the description
while containerizing a single Tomcat
Java application manually is possible
containerizing tens or even hundreds of
applications is a long labor-intensive
and error-prone process with migrate to
Containers you are able to orchestrate
and automate these migrations at scale
using migration pipelines to learn more
about migrating VMS to containers at
scale you can visit our GitHub
repository to experiment with our
example pipeline which is powered by
tecton we'll provide a link to that repo
in the description as well
when looking at migrating existing
Tomcat applications to Containers there
are four discrete steps to the migration
process first is Discovery and
assessment migrate has a fit assessment
tool that can be used to help identify
what workloads you have running and
which are the best candidates for
migration we recently released an
updated fit assessment video which you
guessed it we will link in the
description
next is setup and planning including
deciding where your migrated application
will ultimately run as I mentioned
earlier migrated Tomcat applications can
be run on gke in standard or autopilot
mode anthos and Cloud run
the third phase is the actual migration
since that's the focus of the remainder
of this video I won't spend a lot of
time describing it here
the Final Phase deals with how you
manage applications after they've been
migrated because migrate to Containers
provides you with the resulting Docker
file deployment yaml and any additional
dependencies you can easily manage
updates to your code via your standard
deployment Pipelines
let's double back and drill down a bit
into the steps associated with the third
phase and what you'll see in the
upcoming Demo First we'll create a gke
autopilot cluster then we're going to
provide migrate to Containers as Source
VM
the migrant processes will inspect the
VM and generate a migration plan that we
can edit as needed from there it will
generate the deployment artifacts and a
build script which we will use to build
a Docker container we'll then deploy
that container onto our autopilot
cluster
with that let's jump into our demo
okay so as I mentioned the first thing
we're going to do is set up an autopilot
cluster so we'll come in here I'll click
create I'll select autopilot and click
configure and because it is an autopilot
cluster I don't have to worry about
provisioning out nodes or networking
security any of that stuff I basically
just give it a name I pick a region and
I click create so we'll call this one
Tomcat deploy
and then we'll come down and we'll leave
it in the region we'll click create
the next step is to ensure the VMS we
want to migrate are stopped and they are
and you'll notice here that there's
actually a VM for a database and then
one for our Tomcat front end I've
already migrated the database so I'm not
going to do that in this video we're
just going to focus on migrating this
Tomcat VM right here
now we're going to create a migration
Source a migration Source just tells
migrator containers where to find our
source VMS so I choose my processing
cluster I give my source a name we'll
call this Tomcat source I'll click next
down here we're going to go ahead and
let it create a service account for us
and that's all it takes to Define our
source so with the source defined we can
start our actual migration
and we do that by clicking create
migration
then we give our migration a name we
call it Tomcat migration we'll select
the source from the drop down which is
the source we just created
we're doing a tomcat container for this
migration
and we're migrating off of this Tomcat
pet clinic virtual machine so with that
we'll click create migration and that
will Define a migration plan which we
can edit in the next step
and here's that migration plan it
defines a bunch of things about how we
want to migrate our container for this
video we're just going to take off this
unique identifier here at the end of the
name for both the container and the
migration itself so we'll get rid of
this because we don't need it since
we're just migrating one container so
let me delete this I'll come down I'll
delete this
and then we're going to save this off
and we're going to generate our
artifacts and those will be the final
thing we need to actually deploy our
application this takes a couple minutes
so I'm going to go ahead and stop the
video and I'll rejoin you when it's
finished the artifacts have been built
and I've downloaded them here into Cloud
shell if you look you'll see here we've
got this scaffold.yaml we use scaffold
here to deploy our actual application so
let me issue the scaffold run command
that's going to go out and it's going to
build the container it's going to push
it up to the registry and then it's
going to actually deploy the kubernetes
services and the deployments and the
stateful sets Etc that we need for our
application to run so I'm going to go
ahead and speed this up in the video and
I'll rejoin you when it finishes
now that that's finished let's go ahead
and grab the kubernetes service that was
deployed so we can get the external IP
address
put that up in our browser and that's
going to show our running application
so what we've done here is we've taken
and migrated the application from a
virtual machine to a container using
migrate to containers
I hope that demo showed you how easy it
can be to not only deploy a gke
autopilot cluster but also how simple it
can be to migrate an existing VM based
workload to kubernetes
for more detailed information check out
our documentation as well as the other
videos in our migrate series and don't
forget to like And subscribe to be
alerted whenever we publish new content
[Music]